ahora es buen momento para ver la
secadora de cabello en sí así que
empecemos a medida de que subimos por el
conector hasta aquí que es por donde
viene la energía tenemos otra pieza de
como protectora y un pequeño sujetador
moldeado junto lo cual es bueno así
puedes colgar tu secadora de cabello en
el baño si lo deseas y luego tenemos
este interruptor que nos permite
incrementar disminuir y apagar la
energía y luego tenemos estos patrones
moldeados y luego el embudo que canaliza
el aire a través de él y pueden ver que
hay una pantalla en la parte posterior
que ayuda a mantener las cosas fuera así
que vamos a ver qué tiene adentro y voy
a usar un desarmador de cruz para quitar
estos tornillos estos tornillos son
chapa dos están hechos de acero y parece
que están chapados en cromo porque son
muy brillosos y la razón por la que
hacen eso es porque las secadoras se
usan en ambientes húmedos como los baños
por ejemplo y si los tornillos están
hechos de acero se van a oxidar así que
les ponen un recubrimiento para que no
se oxiden como el cromo que no se oxida
y lo protegerá
además porque los tornillos son visibles
y usan este acabado brillante del cromo
porque se ve mejor que un tornillo
pintado además provee una mejor
resistencia a la corrosión que la
pintura ok vamos a quitar todo esto
vamos muy bien
y ahora es momento de observar el
interior
pueden ver que de nuevo esta es una
parte moldeada por inyección los moldes
se juntan de esta forma se inyecta el
plástico y por aquí puedes ver los
pivotes del inyector es decir estas
marcas que tenemos aquí estos son los
que empujan hacia afuera y hacen que
caiga y puedes ver que este material es
llamado pepe lo que significa
polipropileno y las marcas del pivote de
expulsión están justo aquí estas marcas
están dispersas para que los pivotes
pueden empujar el molde uniformemente
hacia afuera además tenemos estos bordes
del interior que proveen una rigidez
estructural y dureza y bueno además
sirven como una ubicación de montaje
para la cubierta del ventilador y la
pantalla de acá atrás parece que fue
colocada con una máquina y fue
presionada contra la parte posterior de
la cubierta donde está la ventilación
parece que el plástico fue calentado y
la pantalla fue puesta dentro del
plástico caliente metiéndola en su lugar
esa es una manera económica de mantener
esas piezas unidas pues no hay tornillos
los tornillos recuerdan agregan
así que es una manera con la que son
capaces de reducir costos y ahora vamos
a apartar estos momentos y si venimos y
observamos dentro vamos a ver el
interruptor de aquí por aquí es por
donde viene la energía y aquí tenemos
esta parte que es muy interesante muchas
veces puedes ver que los fabricantes
atan el cable de alimentación en un nudo
pero en este caso no está atado a un
nudo lo atraviesan por este tornillo de
refuerzo o dónde va el tornillo y la
razón por la que hacen eso es para que
no lo pueda sacar definitivamente no
quisieras estar en una situación en la
que el cable sea parte del interruptor y
tal vez tengas un contacto eléctrico
libre que toque algunas cosas y haga
cortocircuito y eso provoque que tu
secadora de cabello deje de funcionar
que esto lo protegen aquí y también hay
otra pose de seguridad vamos a sacar el
interruptor y pueden ver que hay un
soporte de plástico donde el interruptor
entra muy bien y lo mantiene estable en
su lugar y bueno este interruptor tiene
tres diferentes ajustes
y espero que tú no puedas ver así que
déjenme acercar un poco este interruptor
a la cámara y dice tenemos 16 amperes y
125 votos y 8 amperes y 250 volts así
que este interruptor puede manejar una
buena cantidad de corriente y bueno por
acá pueden ver que hay diferentes cables
que salen del interruptor y van as el
calentador este cable de aquí está unido
con esta conexión de latón y ya que la
conexión está abierta hay una pieza de
plástico transparente que paz sobre eso
y esto evita el contacto con otras
partes del interruptor que provoquen un
cortocircuito y causen un problema aquí
tenemos otro tornillo muy pequeño es más
vamos a sacarlo y es la parte posterior
del interruptor esto mantiene la parte
frontal del interruptor en su lugar y es
una pieza de plástico moldeado por
inyección y en la parte posterior se
desliza en este canal de aquí justo así
de esta manera e interactúa con el
interruptor en sí
solo una pieza que parece acrílico
moldeado que se encaja contra el
interruptor y te permite transmitir el
movimiento de afuera al interior del
aparato
muy bien y por acá tenemos el ventilador
tenemos estas dos piezas de santo pleno
que son solo piezas de adorno de goma
moldeada y seguramente están ahí más por
cuestiones de diseño
vamos a continuar quitando esto para ver
si podemos sacar la unidad de
calentamiento y antes de echar un
vistazo a eso vamos a ver esto de aquí
esto de aquí es el embudo y como saben
la secadora de cabello se calienta y ese
calor puede causar que el plástico se
ponga muy duro o blando así que colocan
esta pieza dentro que es una lámina de
mi cama y básicamente protegen la
cubierta de que se caliente demasiado
cuando el calentador se calienta y si
vemos en esta parte de atrás tiene un
soporte una pequeña tapa que está hecha
de acero es solo un acero pintado y está
protege de las cosas que puedan entrar
al calentador y de nuevo observa no hay
tornillos recuerda que esto ayuda a
reducir costos
esta fue moldeada por inyección de igual
manera que en esta otra pieza y el molde
se une
por ambos lados y luego el pivotes que
empujan el plástico hacia fuera una vez
que éste haya endurecido y todo y si
observamos aquí podemos ver que tenemos
alambres del cromo y lo fascinante de
esta secadora de cabello es que toman
este alambre de cromo y lo usan como una
resistencia masiva porque tu motor no
quiere 220 volts de corriente alterna
que llegan él quiere una energía alterna
y necesita trabajar en 12 volts y la
manera en la que lo reduce es usando el
calentador como una resistencia que
disminuye el voltaje a 12 volts así que
es una manera ingeniosa para hacer esto
y bueno el calentador está hecho de
estos espirales de aquí que es un
alambre de cromo están hechos de un
material llamado ni cromo él ni cromo es
una aleación de níquel y cromo y cuando
la electricidad pasa a través de él se
calienta y se caliente de una manera en
que es bastante efectiva para obtener
calor cuando la energía corre a través
de él
no se oxida en muchas ocasiones cuando
se calienta un metal esta es oxida se
corroe y tienes problemas con eso pero
en este caso solamente se calienta y se
enfría y no hay oxidación así que
funciona muy bien como un calentador y
al frente pueden ver este soporte que
mantiene todo separado a 90 grados el
cual mantiene todo trabajando desde el
flujo de aire y cosas así además
mantiene esta lámina de mica separada y
pueden ver en el interior que tenemos
contactos de latón son pequeños remaches
de latón y estos distribuyen la energía
y esta parte justo aquí es una banda
metálica y esa banda bien metálica está
hecha de dos piezas de metal y lo que
hacen es que cuando el metal se calienta
a un cierto punto provoca que la banda
bimetálica se doble y es que ésta se
forma de una pieza de metal que tiene un
diferente interés de expansión que la
otra pieza de metal y provoca que la
banda se doble así que no sé si
suponemos que esta es la banda metálica
entonces
bandas se expanden más rápido que la
otra y provoca que se doblen así que
puedes tener dos diferentes tipos de
metal como no sé una aleación llamada
inbar y la otra pieza de un metal
llamado cobre y el cobre va a responder
al calor en un cierto ritmo y éste se va
a expandir mientras que el inba no se va
a expandir tan rápido como el cobre y
eso provocará que el interruptor se abra
y todo esto le va a cortar la energía al
calentador así que si se pone muy
caliente la banda metálica se expandirá
y se alejará del contacto lo que hará
que se corte la electricidad al
calentador además puedes ver por aquí un
diodo justo aquí este diodo está en
línea y lo que hace es controlar el
flujo de electricidad es como una
pequeña válvula eléctrica y luego
tenemos una resistencia técnica justo
aquí no espera no no es una resistencia
técnica es un fusible térmico y un
fusible técnico básicamente es otra
precaución de seguridad si la
temperatura llega a ser muy alta es
fusible explotara
a la secadora de cabello y esto evitará
que la cubierta se derrita o que la
secadora de cabello se sobrecaliente y
posiblemente exploten y te pueda quemar
recuerda que el calentador funcionan
como una resistencia disminuye el
voltaje a 12 volts pero seguimos
teniendo corriente alterna ac por sus
siglas en inglés y la corriente alterna
básicamente funciona como una onda
senoidal así que fluye adelante y atrás
y el motor que tenemos aquí está
diseñado para trabajar en corrientes
directas que fluyen en un ciclo continuo
y la manera en que este aparato está
secadora de cabello trata con eso es que
tienen estos cuatro diodos es más pueden
verlos
1 2 3 4 y lo que esos diodos hacen es
que funcionan como un puente
rectificador convierte en la corriente
alterna en corriente directa y lo hacen
de una manera muy económica ya que los
diodos son muy baratos así que una vez
que disminuye el voltaje y la energía es
convertida el ventilador comienza
a crear giran y jala al aire y puedes
ver estas rejillas justo aquí las cuales
ayudan al flujo del aire así soplan a
través del calentador en el sentido
correcto ya dentro del motor no voy a
desarmar el motor en este vídeo lo haré
en el siguiente pero adentro del motor
hay un devanado de cobre y también hay
algunos imanes y la electricidad provoca
que el motor gire y después saca el aire
a través del calentador y la razón por
la que hace esto es que el aire caliente
puede retener más humedad que el aire
frío y seca tu cabello mucho más rápido
todas las secadoras de cabello solían
ser alrededor de 100 watts o tal vez un
poco más que eso
así que tomaba más tiempo secar tu
cabello porque no tenías la misma
energía técnica que esta que tiene 1875
watts esta es casi la energía técnica
que puede producir un circuito de 20
amperes está muy cerca al límite en
cualquier caso esta es una hélice de
plástico y está por acá parece
cubierta de acrílico una cubierta de
plástico transparente y por acá tenemos
otro diesel que permite dirigir el flujo
del aire y además mantener al motor en
su lugar pero bueno esto es lo que tiene
adentro una secadora de cabello así que
espero que lo hayas disfrutado